genre
as-tu déjà participé à des émissions de
télévision sous l'emprise de substances
illicites
alors Jean Rochefort comme vous êtes en
très bonne santé tout le monde peut le
constater c'est le moment de vous faire
une interview jugement dernier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'heure du jugement dernier
Jean es-tu prêt pas encore mais bon
genre oui as-tu cru en moi
à une époque oui pourquoi as-tu cessé de
croire en moi
parce que j'ai cessé parce que j'ai cru
en vous par trouille de la mort et je
sais que vous n'arrangerez rien là-haut
tu fais chier genre
as-tu déjà péché par penser par action
par omission ou à la mouche
[Musique]
pêcher à la mouche jamais
par omission jamais et par penser tout
le temps
as-tu foutu en l'air un tournage en
prétextant un quelconque mal au dos
non j'ai foutu en aléatoire en
prétextant une douleur dans le périnée
qui est situé entre l'anus et les
testicules
genre as-tu déjà participé à des
émissions de télévision sous l'emprise
de substances illicites non mais ce soir
j'aurais dû
Jean
as-tu déjà regardé TF1 le samedi soir en
deuxième partie de soirée non non jamais
pourvu que ça dure
non as-tu déjà commis l'acte de chair
son volonté reproductrice
oui de nombreuses fois et je regarde un
souvenir épatant les gens de saillie à
l'époque
[Applaudissements]
non je ne suis pas un trompeur j'ai eu
des grandes passions mais je ne trompais
pas je partais est-ce que tu te repends
de tous tes péchés Jean non c'était le
plus agréable et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de Inna larditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu